we talked about the draft a little bit
with peter schrager my colleague from
good morning football and nfl network
and fox sports
and joining me here on the rich eisen
show pleased to say he's
our first 2021 draft prospect correct
chris
yes could be one of the top if not the
top defensive prospect
taken in this year's draft from the
university of michigan quitting pay how
are you sir
i'm doing all right go blue go blue
right back at you
where where do i find you right now are
you in ann arbor
still training where are you right now
where do i find you i'm currently in
arizona
you're in arizona getting ready okay um
and what are you doing down there
in arizona so i'm training at the exos
facility out here in
phoenix and what are you
doing there like what are you what are
you working on because there is no
i guess you're you're i must you you
must be working on your your drills for
uh pro day i imagine later on this month
in ann arbor right
yes our pro days uh march 26th so i'm
just
although they cancel the combination uh
uh we're still gonna have the
opportunity to run the 40s through our
shuttles and
uh position work at our pro day so just
preparing for that all right what's your
40 what are we aiming for here quiddy
what do you got for me
man i'm trying to uh we just recently
did like
our lasers a little while ago and um
laser was
four five nine i like 272 or so
i proved it hopefully i can go a little
bit lower four
five nine and what are you weighing
right now what are you tipping the
scales out right
272-ish oh my god dude that's not fair
yes sir that would be something that
would definitely catch some eyes here
have you been doing zoom interviews yet
yeah i've been been doing a pretty good
amount
all right drop some names who's who
who's chatting with you quiddy
who you've been chatting with uh
i mean i just i've pretty much been
talking uh everybody so i
pretty much did one interview with like
all teams so far so uh
yeah so have you gotten a second
interview with anybody yet
uh not yet no okay so what's the
craziest question you've been asked in
these interviews
quitting um i mean it was all like all
baseline uh interviews you know kind of
just ask my background
if you've been arrested uh like just
stuff like that just
um questions that they have to ask all
their all the prospects going on so it's
been pretty like bland interviews kind
of like
the same questions over and over again
but uh yeah
so nobody's trying to throw you off your
game with a stupid dumb ass question yet
that hasn't happened yet
no not yet okay i mean i could bounce
some off you but i i think you'll just
be able to handle it
uh when it all comes down to it let's
talk about your your journey
um and uh how you wound up
um in this country to begin with
obviously you came here
as a as an infant correct from uh
from from a war-torn spot on planet
earth right is that correct you and your
family
yes sir yeah so i was born in uh guinea
but my family's from liberia and uh
at the time there was a civil war going
on over there so uh
born in a refugee camp in guinea and
then fled there to
come to america at like six months old
and your family settled where
we saw those in providence rhode island
how did you get a problem
how did you wind up from a liberian
refugee camp to
rhode island united states of america
quitting how did that happen
so uh my mom had like awesome uncles
there so we came there and we lived with
them for a little while so we got on our
own feet but
yeah kind of like rhode island was like
very like a random spot but
yeah we just happen to have family there
and that's where we settle
so okay and uh when did you first know
that you could uh play football quiddy
so at first we were running track and uh
my mom she didn't like the idea of us
playing football but
we ended up begging her we ended up
forcing her to bring us to the field and
sign us up for football and then
at around like the age of eight or seven
that's when like we really got into it
and started playing popcorn and all that
stuff and then
we just fell in love with the sport and
then when did you start to
uh grow into the grown-ass man that you
are and realize that you might actually
be able to
be special at this sport when did that
first happen is there a coach who turned
you on
a certain way or what i mean like uh
i ended up getting like a growth spurt
like in high school so coming into high
school i was like
5 10 or whatever and then like my
sophomore year in high school you would
be like
six two so then uh that's when i started
to put
on a lot of more weight and then whatnot
then i would say kind of like my
freshman winter training cycle when our
new strength staff came
in i was like still 240 at the time and
then
after coach herb and staff was done uh
uh creating monsters i was like 270.
so i i give a lot of credit to our
strengths for uh
making me who i am today in high school
you're talking about
no in in college in the university of
michigan okay
so now let's get to there when did you
first quitty pay here on the rich eisen
show and mock drafts have him
potentially being the first defensive
player selected in this year's draft
um so certainly one of the top pass
rushers available
when's your first meet with uh harbaugh
jim harbaugh when did that happen
so i met with coach harbaugh for the
first time um
uh my official visit when i came and
they played wisconsin that's when uh
jordan lewis had that one-handed pick to
uh seal the game off
and um that was my first time ever
meeting coach harbaugh in his office
with my stepfather
and so what made you want to decide to
hook up in michigan with him what uh
walk me through that
i think it was a no-brainer um but at
the same time coach brown
had offered me when i was committed to
boston college so
i came into coach brown and uh he ended
up getting the michigan gig
so when he went to michigan uh we got
back in contact and then he offered me
again and that's someone who i wanted to
play for so
make sure i committed against the uh
cliff or gold blue and yeah exactly
right so
um why play um
you know you decided to stick around and
then here comes the pandemic
quitty um what was that like when
you know the big ten said we're gonna
play and then we're not gonna play
and where where were you and the rest of
the team on
on that front when that was going down
in the painting so um
so uh we were practicing actually um and
we took like a
a short break before we came back to do
like our afternoon practice
so um that's when obviously all our
phones were blowing up
and like news of like the big ten has
been canceled and coach hardware had
called a meeting
on the outdoor field and then he said
yeah like they came for the big ten
season but
even though they came to the season we
never stopped practicing so
uh nothing in our building changed we
were still practicing
our schedule didn't change at all um
so yeah so you were you wanted to play
you and the
predominantly everyone all the kids
everybody
for the maze and blue wanted to play the
2020 season
and then you were told that exactly yeah
not i mean what were you thinking about
at that point in time knowing that you
stuck around
you didn't go in the draft you were
gonna come back and now you
had a possibility of not playing a
single down of football prior to your
big
you know uh leap to the nfl what was
going through your mind at the time
quitty pay um when they announced the
news like i remember just sitting down
like man
i don't get to play my last season with
uh my brothers
and um i sat for a long time and then um
even though it came to see gamers i had
the opportunity to like go ahead and
start training and get to jump on
you know everything i was just like i'll
stick around
and i was teaching a bunch of the young
guys everything i've learned over
my three years at michigan to leave them
with uh some knowledge and whatnot how
to play the game
and certain things i picked up over my
time at michigan so
even though i can't succeed even though
like i could have left i made sure i
stayed and i was with uh
all my guys because i was like i'm i'm
never gonna play with you guys again so
might as well just enjoy my time while i
can with you guys and then
then to bring the season back and i was
alright bet
and then you you unfortunately couldn't
finish it yourself how are you feeling
right now how are you ready to go i'm
feeling i'm feeling great right now um
even though i got injured throughout the
season i made sure i came back
uh played that penn state game and that
just so happened to be
the last game before they canceled our
last three games so
even though i wasn't 100 for the penn
state game uh
i wouldn't say that that experience for
anything you know just to be able to
shoot up with my brothers for the last
time and whatnot but then yeah uh
i'm all healthy now uh uh excellence
fixed me completely so
yeah i'm glad to hear that and i just
want to give you the floor on this
because
it was a big to-do at the time um
some people were saying and some people
of note were saying that michigan was
ducking
ohio state using covet as a shield
what do you say to something like that
quittipe uh i mean
uh the media does what they want and
they portray stories
and you know try and gas things up but
not like we were all practicing like we
were looking forward to that game even
though season's gonna
go as we as we wanted to that's why you
go to michigan to play that
game you know nobody was deaf and smoke
uh you know if we could go back and play
that game like we would all go back to
school and play that game so
uh we wanted all the smoke um and yeah
like
i don't i don't know where that
narrative came from but uh a lot of
people on our team started getting
covered and obviously we couldn't play
with uh
the outbreak so if we could play then we
we would have for sure played you wanted
all that smoke
huh i like it that's i guess that's what
you
that's what you suit up for is is for
the smoke what's your favorite harbaugh
story
you got one for me my favorite hard wash
story i don't think i've told many
people about this
story but um it was not my official
visit
and uh coach harbaugh like he drives
around like the big like uh sprinter van
sometimes because uh he has a large
family
yes and um it was uh i was rashawn's uh
recruit
uh to host rashaan gary and um he was
bringing over here
yeah okay he was bringing us back to um
algebra sean gears and carlo kemp's uh
recruit
and then um he was bringing us back to
west squad and the sprinter ran and then
like
in the back of like soft quad it's like
a um
it's like this one i call the sack i
would say and um he didn't want to take
like a u-turn and go back up the street
and take a left and drop us off so
he just hopped on the sidewalk and he
just because it was just like a small
style like that he could just hop over
so
hopped over that then she dropped us off
at west squad and then
just went on his way but yeah like after
that they made us that's hilarious
well i mean you know there's some he he
was also a big man on campus there in
the in the 80s too you know he was
he was the quarterback of my my freshman
year team when i went there
he was the one who who who guaranteed
win over ohio state and beau shembachler
did not uh
appreciate that one little bit but uh
all of us on campus sure did so
you know i i you know and it did so did
did you not eat chicken because it's a
nervous bird
did you do that based on your coaches uh
we
we we ate a lot of steak i would say
steak was the
primary meal that we would eat uh before
all our games we had steak
um victory dinner we had steak and uh
yeah there
there wasn't much chicken being in in
the building all right
all right quitty pay uh before i let you
go um
tell me and everybody else uh
what a team would be getting if they
drafted quitty pay
in the 2021 draft who who are they
getting what are they getting
quitty uh they'll be getting a blue
collared
worker you know a guy that comes in for
doing every every single day looking for
opportunity to get some more work and a
very athletic guy that can pretty much
play anywhere in the box so
very versatile um and you're just just a
a competitor looking for the smoke
you're looking for smoke
yes they're looking for all the smoke
quitty pay thank you for the time good
luck to you let's chat
as you get to the next level when you
get to the next level i'm rooting for
you as you know
sir thank you you bet that's quitty pay
of the university of michigan coming
soon to the national football league
looking for all the smoke
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here